so for you this creation began back in
1991 and I know that's a while ago but
I'm hoping you can remember for us the
scene or the image that launched this
series a song of ice and fire it was the
it was the first chapter of the novel
Game of Thrones not not the prologue
which actually appears first I brought
that later but it was the the chapter
where they brand viewpoint and they
write out to see the the deserter
beheaded and then they find the dire
wolf pups and in the summer snow I was
actually I was the summer of 1991 and I
was working it was sort of the middle of
my Hollywood decade I was doing a lot of
development and pilot scripts and future
scripts and but I had no particular
assignment that summer so I returned to
my home in New Mexico and said well I
might as well start work on this novel
that I've been thinking of for like ten
years a science fiction novel set in my
established future history and I was
writing that and moving along well and
suddenly this scene came to me I didn't
know what it was I knew it wasn't part
of the novel that I was writing it was
obviously a fantasy and medieval fantasy
not a futuristic science fiction thing
but it came to me so vividly and so
strongly that I just felt compelled that
I had to write it so I put aside what I
was doing and I wrote that chapter and
that chapter led to another chapter and
that chapter led to another chapter and
you know what a certainty you more I'm
sorry yeah not all there in the summer
1991 but I knew I was doomed when I drew
the map and then you had to take it
seriously so I drew a map and and but
then the Hollywood thing kicked up again
so I actually wound up putting in a
drawer for a few years and returned and
did another pilot and you know did
another screenplay and it was all that
time that I was working on other
projects in Hollywood I couldn't get
this this world or these characters out
of my head I was being haunted by bran
and Arya and Aryan and finally a couple
years later I returned to it and wrote
some more pages and said to my agent why
don't you see if you can sell this and
thankfully we did he certainly did and
you know you mentioned chapters you
mentioned pages but when did it
change George from being a novel so I
think there was an idea that it would be
a trilogy - now these seven are you know
we've got five we're anticipating seven
massive epic volumes it well it it
wasn't a novel for very long I but even
by the time I sold it it was a trilogy
we sold the first series as a trilogy I
had about I think 200 pages that I gave
to my agent and I think I attached a
two-page projection of what the rest of
the story would be because they don't
write like writing outlines I have never
liked writing outline so I wasn't going
to do a big formal outline of the other
three books but it was gonna be three
books a game of Thrones a dance with
dragons the winds of winter those were
three original titles and you know
somehow a dance with dragons kept
receding into distance as I you know I I
I began working on Game of Thrones and
it got longer and longer my original
projection was three books of about 800
manuscript pages each which was long I
mean my preceding novels things like
fever dream and the Armageddon rag had
been about 500 550 pages of manuscript
so 800 page manuscript was was a long
book and fantasies were traditionally
longer than science fiction books are
horrible so I thought that would do it
and when I'm writing the first one you
know I hit 800 pages and the no end was
in sight
I had 900 pages and no end was inside I
hit a thousand pages and no end was in
sight and by the time I hit like 1400
pages and still no end was in sight I
said maybe it's four books so I suddenly
Clash of Kings was born and I juggled
with the structure a little I move some
of the chapters I'd already written and
I delivered basically an eleven hundred
page manuscript that became Game of
Thrones and I had a 300 page head start
on Clash of Kings we were ahead of the
game and yeah at a certain point though
I realized well four books four books is
not gonna be four books it's gonna be
six books I said six for a long time
I skipped right over five I
never never fooled around with five I
started saying would be six books and
Paris my wife who was who was dead my
girlfriend would attendees think with me
and people would ask me how long serious
gonna be and I would say six books and
behind me she would be holding up seven
fingers you know better than I did
ahead of time so now I'm saying seven
books and that's my story and I'm
sticking to it
okay well we will believe you for now
for now